[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
hasta agosto de 2021 más del 57% de la
población en los países de ingresos
altos fue vacunada contra el cou y 19
algo que contrasta con sólo el 21 por
ciento de los habitantes en países de
bajos ingresos que recibieron dosis
contra el coronavirus según naciones
unidas así las cosas falta un camino
largo para lograr una equidad en la
inoculación esta diferencia tiene un
impacto significativo en la aplicación
de las fórmulas en la población migrante
y refugiada en el mundo veamos cuáles
son las cifras hasta ahora conocidas al
respecto
para evaluar cómo va la vacunación en la
población migrante y refugiada en el
mundo la organización mundial de la
salud reviso un total de 104 programas
nacionales de inoculación presentados al
mecanismo kóvacs la plataforma mundial
que busca un acceso equitativo a las
dosis contra el kobe 19 los resultados
revelaron que la mayoría de países un
72% no incluyó explícitamente a los
migrantes en sus planes de vacunación y
un poco más de la mitad nombró a
refugiados y solicitantes de asilo en su
estrategia de inoculación contra la
pandemia los datos son mínimos para la
población migrante en situación
irregular sólo el 17 por ciento de las
104 estrategias revisadas por la o ms lo
tienen en cuenta y aunque los gobiernos
señalan que trabajan por un acceso
equitativo a las dosis organizaciones
internacionales consideran que esto
dista mucho de la realidad por ejemplo
los refugiados y solicitantes de asilo
reciben vacunas contra el coronavirus en
101 de los 162 países supervisados por
acnur mientras que la oye me informó que
en mayo de 2021 sólo los migrantes en
condición regular es decir los que
ingresaron los oficiales y permanecen en
los países bajo los criterios de
admisión de cada uno fueron vacunados
los datos dan cuenta de una serie de
obstáculos que dificultan el acceso a
las dosis el suministro limitado a las
vacunas la falta de confianza e
información sobre el acceso a las dosis
las barreras lingüísticas la falta de
documentación los complejos procesos de
registro el miedo al arresto oa la
deportación un estudio en población
migrante y refugiada en reino unido-
reveló que el 72 por ciento de los
consultados tenían dudas sobre el
contenido de las fórmulas y sus efectos
secundarios mientras que otra medición
de la cruz roja y la media luna roja
detalló que un 90 por ciento de los
encuestados adultos faltan de
conocimientos sobre el acceso a las
vacunas el 67 por ciento identificó
barreras de idioma lado ms descubrió
también que no todos los migrantes
entrevistados buscarían atención médica
en caso de sospecha de infección por
falta de recursos económicos para
costear el tratamiento y por miedo a ser
deportados
la región de las américas ha dado un
buen ejemplo en cuanto a la inclusión de
los migrantes y refugiados en sus planes
de vacunación en países de áfrica y asia
también se avanza en el proceso y el
medio oriente en jordania el 30 por
ciento de los refugiados con derecho a
una dosis habría recibido al menos la
primera inyección a finales de mayo así
avanzan las campañas de inoculación en
otras naciones este gimnasio deportivo
es ahora un gran centro de vacunación
contra el kobe 19 en yakarta el objetivo
es administrar unas 700 dosis al día y
muchas están listas para ser inyectadas
a refugiados
estoy feliz
correcto porque el commit 19 es un gran
problema y si bien la vacunación avanza
todavía faltan miles por ser inmunizados
en indonesia hoy tenemos alrededor de
2400 de los 13.000 400 refugiados que
han sido vacunados
[Música]
estos 2400 recibieron su primera banda
por supuesto esperamos si tenemos que
trabajar con todos los refugiados para
tener acceso a las dosis
en indonesia sólo el 10% de la población
tiene el esquema completo de vacunación
en libia los migrantes reciben dosis
contra el cob y 19 en el principal
centro de detención de trípoli con la
campaña se espera a inocular a 825 de
ellos al día con la vacuna china sinovac
los migrantes reciben las dosis de
manera voluntaria y es un esfuerzo por
contener el virus entre los que están en
tránsito es extremo y en forma es
sumamente importante luchar contra la
pandemia y que todo el mundo esté
vacunado
actionaid 7 es un tema de salud para los
migrantes que nos preocupa mucho pero
también es una cuestión de salud pública
porque sólo si todos estamos vacunados
es que podremos superar la pandemia
a kilómetros de allí en tailandia la
cruz roja aplica dosis a trabajadores
migrantes y refugiados sin documentos y
aunque la participación ha sido alta el
reto es llegar a todos los extranjeros
si un registro que necesitan una dosis
[Música]
vimos las noticias en facebook youtube y
otros medios vemos lo que está pasando y
pensamos en nuestra salud en lo que
vamos a hacer con nuestras vidas hoy me
siento seguro vaya el
agua
vinimos como un grupo porque le tememos
a la muerte es un alivio estar aquí
donde finalmente alguien nos está
prestando ayuda material torneo match y
thiago by ya datos oficiales muestran
que más de 2.300.000 migrantes tienen
permisos de trabajo pero la organización
internacional para las migraciones
estima que son al menos 5 billones
laborando en tailandia
según recomendaciones del grupo de
expertos sobre inmunización de la
organización mundial de la salud la
priorización para las vacunas debe
respetar los derechos humanos de toda la
población y garantizar un acceso
universal e igualitario
independientemente de su estatus
migratorio
hasta aquí inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]